this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
in space everybody's favorite Gary
Brannen go runnin nice to see you to see
you and the bouncy smell on the internet
that great you plunder yeah I plug
nothing in front be I've got a score
from Wikipedia and these folks can't see
it every fact to get right is a point
and a ding and the special prize for
people good answers which is
and today we are talking about Juan
Pujol Garcia one patrol because the two
of them is on his own it's it's a good
job assistant Qi Gary because at that
point large can I guess that this person
is from a Spanish or Portuguese speaking
country oh yeah Spain hey I don't know
very much about Spain it's funny you say
that you don't know much about Spain did
he neither he didn't know much about
England and that became important during
part of his life
did you just end up here what's this I'm
gonna have a run at this one I miss it
but was he some kind of captain of the
Spanish Armada oh no you're far far far
too early for that was he not the
captain of any kind of Spada
yes but you're not getting a point for
saying he's not something was he not the
first man to walk on the moon it's true
if it was too early for an hour Marty's
gonna be too early for the moon
no he's too he's too late for an armada
too late or not the Armada was too early
for him yes the centuries d'etre not if
the Train miss me he cries he was
centuries late for Armada he was born in
1912 died in 1988 uh-huh that doesn't
help much it doesn't but he had a
codename did he know given given those
dates why might you want a code spies
yes is this doing the couldn't patron
was he a spy placed in England but he
just didn't know anything about the face
so was he a spy no he was a spy a place
in England to look after sheep and
therefore was a shepherd spy
[Laughter]
two people in the audience just going no
no he was he was an excellent spy but
for which side and we're talking World
War two both yes absolutely right he was
a double agent is he involved in the man
who never was thing know what this was
not operation mincemeat right this was
this was not someone in that who was
sending information both ways wasn't
that hmm
this was this was a man who received
both an Iron Cross from Germany and an
MBE from Britain how can that make him a
good spy surely that makes him it's only
for one of those sides don't don't
so during the early days of World War
two he decided he had to make a
contribution for the good of humanity
and he went to the British who said all
right
now three different times they turned
him down as a spy so what did he do
instead oh did he just go in and start
feeding us information without without
asking him to that's dreadfully rude of
him but rolly useful he certainly helped
the British without asking but not by
talking to them
did he just dress does a post is a
British spy fed false information to the
Germans spot-on absolutely right he he
created an identity as a fanatically
prone as a Spanish government official
who could travel to London on business
and he just started sending false
reports to the Germans hello I'm a
fanatical Nazi I'm not which meant
everyone's thought he was a spy but he
just wasn't mm-hmm yes a point so the
Germans accepted him and said okay
you're a spy now they gave him equipment
they gave a bit of money and he moved to
Lisbon in Portugal you see the coast
kisi what ships are going round singling
from over there to spy directly but the
weather his instructions were moved to
Britain and recruit a network of British
agents said he pretended he was in
Britain when I was actually in Portugal
yes
closer faster good spy he's such a good
spy that he isn't a spy and everyone
thought he was a spy and then he told
them that he was spying and he wasn't
doing this by house he actually sending
reports him because he is sending
reports yet is he sending them to London
who were then directed via London or
something so they're coming from the
right route he's just throwing them over
the wall and run away no he's staying in
Lisbon for this pretending yes
did he just lie yes what might have used
as the basis for that because remember
he's just sitting in Lisbon sending
radio only false reports about Britain
who is he listening to British radio um
newsreel reports in cinemas but yeah
he's looking at the news and using a
tourist guide to Britain which correct
me if I'm wrong the Nazis could watch
the news as well yes but they still
believed him because they saw it on the
news they thought what he was saying was
correct because he'd seen it on the news
he was confirming the British propaganda
if he's dressed up visits by saying yes
I know these things are then the news
says those things cuz he's already seen
the news then they think he's he's right
yes you're absolutely right that's
pretty much what happened there was one
slide from and he's putting expense
reports in by the way here he's getting
dream now now I'm with it what's the
slight problem with his expense reports
Oh wisp or Chinese currency decimal so
he couldn't Forge the receipts yes it's
really hard to convert decimal to in
Imperial currency system because it's
come it's pegged completely different
yeah more than that he didn't know how
pounds shillings and pence
he'd never been there yes so he's making
mistakes but the reports are still
credible so credible that what happens
do we spend a lot of time trying to find
him and cook because mi v launched a
full-scale spy hunt after they
intercepted his reports his reports are
coming from Portugal because he's
probably raided in there more coding
them across and they'll be crackin that
well then yeah through the ultra program
yes so they did eventually move him to
Britain and they gave him a code name
was it a bit of a shock for him to
actually move to Britain he was given a
code name for a very British drink creme
de menthe
well sure kono agent botherin midnight
what's yours
Bovril but they did change his codename
later to my codename gob oh nice so from
Bovril to gob oh yes so what was he
actually sending we've got a mixture of
three things here complete fiction
what's the other two can use paper
clipping football scars genuine
information of little military value but
you know what football scores is final
okay for one of the phrase worthy
leaving them breadcrumbs of things he
thought might be happening soon so they
would keep drip drip feeding very small
amounts into keep them on the hook oh
you're close but there is one thing they
did heat the first bit of this is
valuable military intelligence he did
actually send proper intelligence to the
Germans it's just one catch with it it
was armored so it was out of day or late
yes
artificially delayed so he sent
perfectly accurate data it was
postmarked in time so and they're gonna
say if we'd only read this quicker this
would have read intercept this because
we read this about three days later than
we could have in if only we had more
staff reading this stuff we would have
got there quicker so they employed more
staff yeah I quote we are sorry they
arrived too late but your last reports
with magnificent the Germans wanted
quicker reports and better encryption
you can get that
well they did what did they send him an
enigma machine yeah it's not an enigma
she misses whole drunkest strongest
codebook that the Germans have what was
Operation fortitude in 1944 a good
hearty breakfast did he come after
oppression 30 92 days no but he came
immediately before another famous
Operation Overlord yes which was d-day
yes
so immediately before Operation Overlord
which the d-day landings operation
fortitude was designed to do what this
is the thing with the inflatable tanks
is it yes it is
stay Dave they made some tank shaped
balloons balloon shaped tanks yeah I
made a position they position them so
much that they would be positioned and
for some reason I've never quite worked
out that was enough despite the fact I'm
almost certain one of them will probably
go ahead and look filled with helium and
my she's got really limp guns
so the except he's gonna send some
genuine information and it's got the
German he's got the German radio
operators listening in all night and he
sends them at 3:00 a.m. some reasonable
maybe slightly too late details of a bit
of what's going on it's an invasion at
me not what happened the Germans were
asleep yes we don't have various leaders
didn't send a reply until 8 a.m.
sorry was a sleep had phone on silent
yes so what does he do because it's now
definitely Tula sends an incensed
message that they aren't listening to it
yes excuses or negligence sends pretty
much the accurate details of the
invasion which is happening right now
and they can't do anything about because
they were too late they are that gives
him a free pass yes yes it does cause
he's like I would have told you had you
been awake at 3 a.m. the Germans paid
Garbo how much over the network of
agents over 27 fabricated people over
years I've got a number here in US
dollars that Germans sent straight to
mi5 am I allowed to guess here Ike Marx
no but we're gonna do Price is Right
rules here as usual closer swear on a
u.s. US dollar US dollars 1944 1 million
I'm gonna say it's about ten dollars 92
because they never actually paid him
because he was in the wrong place at the
wrong time clever I was gonna go for
about 600,000 Matt is closest without
going over three hundred and forty
thousand US dollars went straight from
the German Treasury to the British one
no matter I just like to send a plane
over earnest bombed as with banknotes my
he was presented with some awards for
this best spy and also controversially
worst spy a German military award he's
had the Iron Cross yeah I was hoping
you'd forgotten that that must be an
awkward setup for you because he said he
got George Cross awesome didn't and BA
still wearing the Iron Cross
yes officiously iron crush AIDS mark on
wears breast pocket was he turn up in
Germany to receive awards no it was
awarded by radio and then he received
the physical medal from one of his
German handlers after the war had ended
but if he didn't like the institution
and he had all of these awards from two
different institutions sure he hated
that yes but why did he have to accept
it anyway because otherwise it blow his
cover anybody I killed by some
mysterious agents they probably thought
still existed at the time yes he feared
reprisals after the war because we all
assumed like neatly the war ended in 45
they weren't very sure the war was
actually over for quite a long time
because it kind of thought they'll be
back like they are in films that there's
like a secret cachet of Nazis that when
asked to the credit see how he pops up
out of the ground well you know 70 years
later they're back anyway um so what do
you do
he's America and lived a quiet life uh
you know I'll give you that he he'd went
to Angola that's not America
and then went to Venezuela like the
disease did so if you say America
Venezuela is an America he also did
something else makes his own death yes
he did he faked his own death from
malaria in 1949 and then change his
identity move to Venezuela and live
doing what hard drugs printing expense
forms money laundering a bookshop
bookshop and gifts your books are full
of spies 1971 British politician Rupert
Allison is trying to track down Garbo
this for his MBA no he's got um but no
one knows his real name does everyone
just know him as bother logo but yes
essentially there was a full name Bovril
Agartha that's a good eventually ours
some tracks down someone who supplied
his full name and you roughly where he
was so what does Allison then do is he
gone through everyone Garcia in
Venezuela but there are loads of them
you know what last close enough I'm
gonna give you the point he went through
every J Garcia in the Barcelona
phonebook and eventually got in touch
with his nephew in Barcelona Barcelona
that's not Venezuela no because no one
knew where he'd gone of course
yeah we know that yeah hello was your it
was anyone you know a spies yes that's
basically what happened and this person
said yes and they believed him that's
exactly the thing I spy wouldn't do now
you make an excellent point there I was
going to say that Pujol traveled to
London and it says here and was received
by Prince Philip at Buckingham Palace
but now you've said that
no because Prince Philip never met him
or you say that he then went to a
Special Forces Club and was reunited
with a group of his former colleagues
who told them he had plastic surgery
well who is exact and so looked and
sounded different cosmos above relax
your old trick doesn't work like it
doesn't the Bond movies right shut up
yes they called every single J Garcia in
the Barcelona phone book they found his
nephew his nephew put the politician in
touch with the original spy and he came
over and met Prince Philip tall
the beaches of Normandy and eventually
died in Caracas in 1988 and is
essentially the greatest spy that
Britain nearly didn't have 'we came over
he brought a big stack of expense forms
for all so at the end of the show
congratulations Chris you in this one
you win a trip to an all-you-can-eat
garlic restaurant I'll you can eat
buffet the Vampire Slayer - Matt grey
I've been Tom Scott we'll see you next
time
you